[Musik]
guten tag was haben dosentomaten mit der
passion christi zu tun wenn es nach milo
rau geht einiges der theater und
filmregisseur hat ein neues evangelium
verfilmt und stellt dabei die
ausbeuterischen verhältnisse auf
italienischen tomaten feldern an den
pranger
damit lieferte er seine eigene antwort
auf die frage was würde jesus heute tun
milo rau deshalb braucht es denn ein
neues evangelium ja gut ich denke jede
zeit braucht neues evangelium es ist ja
so dass die biber das hat mir lustig
weise ein theologe gesagt also meinen
film gesehen hat dass die bibel ja keine
historische erzählung ist sondern es ist
im grunde erzählt das neue testament das
alte ist ja tatsächlich teilweise
historische erzählung aber das neue ist
eine geschichte die sich als haus und
der lösungs geschichte in jederzeit neu
ereignis deshalb hat jede generation
sein seinen neuen jesus film denke und
die neue interpretation was die bibel
und sagen will was jesus uns sagen will
und mit wem wie sie gesagt haben jesus
heute kämpfen
was würde denn jesus im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert auch
predigen
weil man anders dein körper sagen na ja
gut die botschaften die christlichen
botschaften haben den anspruch haben
dass sie auch zeitlos sind sie nehmen
die ja quasi auch wieder auf in einem
gewissen sinne sehen sie das nicht so
dass das zeitlose wahrheiten sind da
drin
ja ja ich würde sogar sagen bedauerlich
aber ist zeitlose weisheit bedauerlich
ja wenn man das buch rein guckt wie das
vor 2000 jahren im kapitalistischen
strafen stadt rom war und wie es heute
ist dann kann man die geschichte eins zu
eins noch verwenden und italien wie
damals was ich damals in palästina
abgespielt hat also gewissermaßen eine
invasion leute werden von der vom land
vertrieben müssen ohne einkommen
arbeiten und so weiter das ist eine
situation die damals bei der invasion
palästina hat auch passiert ist und wo
man riesige menschenmengen hat ohne ohne
heimat ohne rechte ohne papiere sind
heute natürlich die die flüchtlinge aber
auch die italienischen kleinbauern die
bei uns ja auch vorkommen ich glaube wir
sind noch in einer sehr ähnlichen
situation der ausbeutung der firmen
würde und deshalb ich sagen
bedauerlicherweise zeit was ich würde ja
froh sein wenn diese bibel irgendwann
nicht mehr gebraucht wird weil die dinge
gelöst sind
hallo kommen sie zurück sie vermischen
das ja auch sehr klug in ihrem film dass
sie da eigentlich nachzeichnen wo auch
die parallelen sind damals und setzten
ihren jesus in die hoch ausbeuterischen
verhältnisse der tomaten felder in
italien deswegen habe ich auch diese
platz hause dabei und es ist tatsächlich
dort so dass man als arbeiter offenbar
nicht mehr als 30 euro pro tag verdient
5 euro ausgibt für essen und trinken
fünf euro für hin und rückfahrt genau
und bei ihnen ist daneben jesus einst
sozialrevolutionär ein widerstandscamp
zwar richtig genau wann sie es
tatsächlich ein unglaublich mutiger
mensch das ist der protagonist echter
zogen die protagonist genau ist ein
aktivist für für die rechte von von
migrantischen land arbeiten und land
aber in seinem realen leben und seinem
wirklichen leben kam vor ich glaube
zwölf jahren nach nach nach italien zum
studium hat dann im süden gearbeitet
selber um geld zu verdienen sagt ob man
das gemerkt das ist in den ersten großen
streik wirklich gegen die mafia
organisiert damals hat zu neuen gesetzen
geführt die wurden aber nie umgesetzt
und deshalb kann man jetzt mit uns
zurück ähnlich wie jesus und gesagt ich
bin ich gekommen die gesetze zu brechen
sondern sie endlich zu erfüllen und das
war eigentlich das ziel dieser kampagne
da würde die läuft ja im film parallel
zum zum jesus für ihn dass er spielt
jesus und sich selbst ähnlich wie wir
darsteller von pasolini und ergebnissen
haben die da auch schon ihre besseren
oder schlechteren jesus filme gedreht
haben zum beispiel jesus und pasolini
ist mein johannes der täufer oder die
heilige maria von von meiner gibson ist
um einen heiligen
die nämlich wieder auf wie die hatte ich
früher schon gearbeitet meine
morgenstern ich möchte das aber mit
aktivistinnen und aktivisten der brust
in der apostel sind land arbeiten sind
sechs arbeitern sind leute die wirklich
betroffen sind also das ist eine
mischung wo ich versuche gewissen muss
in filmgeschichte die er sehr dominant
ist in materie zusammen zu bringen mit
der wie sie gesagt haben
sozialgeschichte mit den wirklichen
lebens bedingungen die da sind also
botschaft und wort film und und polit
kampagne zusammen zu haben das gerade
wunderbar frau weggenommen schauen wir
uns doch mal rein
bei ihnen solche vermischung ausschaut
wir haben ein ausschnitt für den einzug
in jerusalem
[Musik]
das sind alles roger
unser aller starter kit petra super 3c
die okada
die dort noch kaum noch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
de compostela situation doris mp/kosi
valiant valiant gute idee ist
[Applaus]
man sieht ja also eine neue
passionsgeschichte und gleichzeitig eine
dokumentation dieser revolte the water
della die mieter
was haben sie denn selber für einen
bezug zu jesus einerseits muss ich sagen
dass ich dieses buch das neue dass das
neue testament eigentlich erst gelesen
habe ist richtig detailliert immer
wieder und wieder während ich den film
vorbereitet habe und ich habe eine
doppelte beziehung natürlich dass
einerseits die ganzen zu schreiben die
wir auch machen es sind soziale
beziehungen erkämpft für die höhe des
menschen usw
auf der andern seite finde ich das buch
und auch seien seinen charakter
unglaublich interessant das ist es ja
auch ein buch das nicht verschlagen zum
beispiel das scheitern wäre wollte die
inneren konflikte die in so einer gruppe
aus brechen also das ist ja der einzige
messias sage ich mal der weltgeschichte
referaten und verleugnet wird der ans
kreuz genagelt wird also der wirklich
scheitert er auch als schwieriger
charakter gezeigt wird ein nazi ist
manchmal vielleicht zu war ich manchmal
zu hart
überzeugend und dann verliert er die
kontrolle über seine leute also es ist
ein sehr ehrliches buch aus
verschiedenen perspektiven geschrieben
und das hat mich sehr interessiert also
weil ich ja auf die die gespaltenheit
des menschen oder auch sage ich die
schwierigkeiten von von solidarität zum
beispiel also wir müssen ja die
unterschiedlichsten gruppen
zusammenarbeit und ist das neue
testament ist im grunde ein großes
casting der menschen die an den
peripherien der gesellschaft im leben
und gerade die haben natürlich angst
sich zu exponieren und das wiederholt
sich auch in unserem projekt ich fand es
sehr interessant sie sagen ja selbst von
sich dass sie max ist sind ich frage
mich jetzt aber wenn sie sagen sie haben
diese bibel auch extrem
gelesen während dieses prozesses hat
dass irgendetwas in bezug auf ihre
religiöse musikalität verändert hat das
irgendwie ihren bezug zur religion
verändert diesen film zu realisieren
ich glaube an ein irrtum ist ja auch
dass man marxismus als als als
religionsfeindliche ansieht aber ist das
stimmt nicht per se religions-
freundlich wir kennen ja alle diesen
ausspruch von opium fürs volk
ja ja aber das betrifft ja die rolle der
kirchengeschichte ich glaube das große
problem in der bibel ist dass die kirche
sich das angeeignet hat dieses buch also
ich glaube das war ein leser hat über
die beim ensi bibel genau und ich glaube
dass das waren ein problem für dieses
buch für diese botschaft über 400 jahren
vielleicht tausende von jahren ich
glaube sie als frau können verstehen was
ich dafür zum einen und und ich glaube
es ist die zeit gekommen diese bibel
sich wieder hand sagen ist das volk sich
die wieder an und macht momentan ja auch
der papst als dass man sagt wir ist
damit eigentlich gemeint was ist
vielleicht die rolle der kirche ich will
ja auch nicht nur kritisieren wir haben
sehr eng mit der katholischen kirche
wollte ich zusammengearbeitet wir haben
jetzt sehr eng zusammen gerade in
süditalien ist eigentlich die kirche der
wichtigste player in der
flüchtlingspolitik
man kennt die enzyklika von von
franziskus also ich glaube da ist
momentan wenn wir schon über marxismus
sprechen ein marxist eigentlich an da an
der spitze der kirche zumindest in
großen teilen seiner äußerung das eine
sozialpolitische es wird ihm natürlich
auch in meinem vorgeworfen
das wird ihm von den rechts
konservativen katholiken in original
hoffen wir mal wird nicht geschossen und
da können noch lange so weitermachen wie
seine seine sein berühmter vorgänger
unter dessen ägide ja lustig also
pasolini seinen film gedreht hat das ich
glaube wir sind gerade in einer sehr
revolutionären phase
ich würde nicht mal sagen revolutionärs
und in einer sehr ähnlichen sehr
wahrhaftigen phase wo man wirklich das
buch rein guckt und frage für wen würde
jesus kämpfen und ich glaube nicht für
die glos großen plantagenbetreiber nicht
für die mafia so den weg für diese leute
die da wieder ausgebeutet werden also
ein nein ein evangelium des volkes und
das ist auch das neue jahr an gegen
wirklich ein gewisser hinsicht auf eine
rückkehr eigentlich vielleicht zur bibel
können sie mir das besser erklären was
sie damit meinen wenn sie sagen wir
müssten uns die bibel wieder mehr selber
aneignen also quasi diesen schritt über
die kirche gewissermaßen aus lassen
was meinen sie damit genau also ich
meine auch dass die kirche sich diese
bibel wieder aneignen muss ich glaube
das ist bei allen texten bei allen
classic con sodass versteigt sich in
einer liga die oft sehr konservativ wird
man kennt das ja auch von ich habe es
keine oper inszeniert da gibt es eine
sehr konservative leser von nicht einmal
mozart es in meinem fall
und da muss man sich mal wieder aneignen
und gucken was hat der eigentlichen dem
moment eigentlich geschrieben das hat er
gemeint ist ja nicht was revolutionäres
was was was demokratisch ist auch in
dieser in dieser musik ist im buch drin
und das macht ja jeder jedes zeitalter
als deshalb gibt es in der kirche ja all
diese abspaltung wo man sagt ja aber da
steht auch was anderes in der bibel
drehen als das was wir aktuell hier in
der welt machen und wenn wir sagen wir
berufen uns darauf dann dann lasst uns
mal nachgucken was da nicht drin
sie beziehen sich natürlich jetzt ganz
stark auch mit ihrer kritik auf die
römisch katholische kirche mit dem was
sie sagen und etwas fällt mir auf wenn
sie das so erzählen sie haben doch auch
diese devise am sie sind ja am
nationaltheater in gent und haben da
diese devise dass nicht mehr als 20% des
originaltextes verwendet werden sollte
ist das hier auch ein geflossen weil sie
haben ja nur punktuell zitate der
evangelien drin
also ich muss tatsächlich sagen dass als
ich angefragt wurde von material was zu
machen ist sofort gesagt in jesus film
ich habe schnell gemerkt einen rein
funktionalen jesus hin zu machen
interessiert mich nicht als revisoren
ich als zuschauer wenn wir ehrlich sind
ist der der passende film ist auf die
dauer einfach langweilig weil ihm die
politische dimension fehlt das gleiche
gilt für die mel gibson film
das ist keine ästhetische kritik aber
für mich ist es eine krieg als zuschauer
und auch in kritik in bezug auf was die
bibel ein gesagt und ich wollte die
bibel das neue testament wirklich landen
in der region ich habe mir dann
angeschaut wer ist da nicht was ist da
eigentlich
und das sind dann die die 80 prozent die
die dazu kommen also wie gesagt ein die
bibel ist kein sandalenfilm den als
sandale film zu drehen glaube ich sind
ihr tun
man muss immer suchen was ist die
bedeutung dieses buchs heute und wenn
irgendwann dieses buch wie gesagt keine
bedeutung hat dann hat er sich entweder
erfüllt
oder es ist für uns nicht mehr ließ weil
ich weiss auch nicht aber aktuell hat
das extrem gut gepasst
also wie sieht denn die welt aus die
keine
er braucht ja also jesus kämpft ja
zumindest inder ich sage mal im text an
sich kämpft ja für die würde des
menschen ist dass man gewissermaßen das
was man er sagte auch einmal glaube ich
zu dem priester herren ihr könnt nicht
noch nach dem wort sprechen muss auch
nach dem wort haben dürfen sie dass man
zum beispiel eine beziehung zwischen dem
was wir wissen
wir wollen den planeten ja nicht
zerstören wir wollen uns auch nicht
ausbeuten ich habe eigentlich immer nur
gutmütige menschen getroffen
aber irgendwie trotzdem haben wir ein
regime der ausbeutung geschaffen der
planet steht vor dem kollaps
also wie bringen wir das wieder zusammen
wie können wir ein leben führen das
gewissermaßen nach unserem herzen an
unserem wissen ist und das ist das was
die bibel teilweise radikal sagt also er
räumt ja einmal dass wir uns ist das die
zerstörung des supermarkt er räumt
einmal einen tempel aus und er sagt
irgendwie die letzten werden die ersten
sein also ist nicht so dass vielleicht
die gesellschaftliche ordnung die
wirkliche um der menschen widerspiegelt
und das ist eine revolte wir haben die
revolte der würde genannt für die die
bibel in all ihren widersprüchlichkeiten
und schwierigkeiten und ihren konflikt
uhr wissen steht die uns da interessiert
hat dienst heute hinein zu tun
jetzt sind ja natürlich für sie als
theater- und filmregisseur und autor
eigentlich die evangelien unseres
evangelium nicht unbedingt ihr schon
wenn man trotzdem damit geht was ist
denn ihre frohe botschaft denn das ist
ja die bedeutung eines evangeliums also
meine botschaft ist wir hatten ja eine
eine wiederauferstehung von von von
jesus tatsächlich rom gedreht und
kreuztal wir haben aber gemerkt dass das
funktioniert in dem film irgendwie nicht
kommt nicht vorher abgenommen wird am
kreuz genau wird der wird abgenommen
quasi also nach dem cut das ist fast ein
technischer vorgang dann sieht man das
mittelmeer das ja auch einerseits die
ewigkeit die hoffen aber auch der auch
desto so viele menschen wie man im film
fährt gestorben sind ertrunken sind
und dann gibt es den abstand im abstand
sieht man da ist die tomatensoße ist
leider verschwunden
aber das im grunde sehr gut dass es im
grunde darum geht dass die botschaft von
jesus oder in dem fall von jemand sagen
je weiter geht dass wir gerechte vorteil
wege finden gerechterweise
zusammenzuleben eine würdevolle weise
das im grunde die botschaft weiter
es geht nicht um die person jesu und ich
glaube das ist ja der punkt wo meine
frohe botschaft ankommen soll ich kann
jetzt vielleicht direkt mal kurz den
konsumentinnen sprechen
bei der gelegenheit der kapitalismus ist
ja amoralisch wie wir wissen und wenn
alle sagen wir wollen nur noch für
getreide tomaten essen sagte
kapitalismus dann verkaufe ich nur noch
für getreide thoma also im grunde das
ist meine botschaft nehmen wir unsere
handlungsmacht war und ändern die welt
diese botschaft die sie ansprechen hängt
ja dann damit zusammen dass ivan zanier
auch diese low carb bewegung gegründet
hat also dass man tomaten kaufen kann
die eben fair produziert sind was ist
keine solche tomaten lohse ich habe das
in der schweiz auch nicht unbedingt
gesehen ist ihre botschaft also
angekommen oder ist sie unterwegs also
in deutschland ist sie angekommen dass
wir in 50 supermärkten werden jetzt auch
einen lpg dann das ist wirklich großer
supermarkt kette ist in belgien waren
wir auch ein supermarkt haben weil da
der bald der filmstart ist in der
schweiz sprechen den migros ich hoffe
dass das führt zu was das kommt
natürlich von unten
ich hatte eine interessante besprechung
mit mit dem es mit dem management delays
größte kette in belgien der gesagt finde
ich eine tolle sache
das problem ist nur wenn wir den fairen
tomaten bei uns verkaufen dann sagen wir
ja automatisch damit das alles andere
kriminelle und dann habe ich gesagt ja
das stimmt und ich glaube schenkt man
sich dessen einfach bewusst wird und ich
glaube ich hier nie wieder niemand leute
unterdrücken während er was ist weil es
gibt noch eine andere große ich sag mal
populäres märchenfest schauen dass faire
produkte teurer sind als unfaire
produkte
das stimmt aber auch nicht das ist
einfach der erlös fairer verteilt aber
die produkte sind nicht teurer
tomaten von ihr waren sie nicht teurer
als diese platte die wir hier sehen
also das ist eine sache die wir in
unserer hand liegt
genau mit diesen punkten die sie
verdient haben frage ich mich welchen
stellenwert schreiben sie denn den film
zu genau wenn es um themen wie glauben
geht apa der film eine spezielle rolle
dafür um solche dinge auch zu vermitteln
ich glaube haben zu dürfen in der
analyse der der
der zuschauerinnen daten in deutschland
in österreich dass über 50 prozent der
menschen die sich diesen film anguckt
tatsächlich gläubige sind also das
funktioniert extrem gut mir ist sehr
nachgefragt in den kreisen der
landeskirchen und soweit ich habe extrem
viele debatten mit mit leuten mit
theologin mit mit allen arten die diesen
film absolut religiös lesen andere lesen
die natürlich wie soll ich sagen
sozialrevolutionär die dritten finden
ihn einfach einen schönen berührenden
film einen emotionalen film was er auch
ist ich glaube ein film kann vieles sein
aber ich denke dass der glaube und das
ist ja immer die hoffnung die glaube ich
auch die kirchen haben wenn er die
menschen direkt betrifft wenn er sie
direkt in ihrem handeln vielleicht auch
sich selbst hinterfragen lässt dann hat
man glaube ich ein punkt getroffen um
den es um den es geht wofür eigentlich
glaube ich dieses ganze religiöse system
auch da ist nämlich das richtige leben
sie haben das ganze als sie haben es
zuvor gesagt gliedern sich quasi auch in
eine tradition ein von jesus film
nämlich durch pasolini und mel gibson
nämlich sie alle wie sie haben in der
höhen stadt in süditalien matera gedreht
ihr schaffen aber sonst beschäftigt sich
sehr wenig mit religiösen themen es gibt
so etwa drei projekte die sich diese
haben realisiert haben das hat mich
eigentlich verwundert weil es ja eben
auch hochpolitisch sind und meines
erachtens kunst politik und religion
doch so nahe beieinander sind
also ich würde sagen umso älter ich
werde umso mehr würde ich ihnen recht
geben ich bin natürlich wie jeder in
einer säkularen gesellschaft
aufgewachsen für mich hat da ein kirche
es ist traurig dass zusagen in den
medien fast noch mit pädophilie noch was
zu tun und man muss eigentlich über das
dann auch hinweg kommt da merkt man
plötzlich die flüchtlingshilfe die
seenotrettung und so weiter sind als
kirchliche organisation also aktuell
spielt die kirche eine eine fast schon
befreiungstheologe rolle in europa
selbst ist was schon gegen bastion zu
einer sehr sehr unmenschlichen
wirtschaftspolitik der eu geworden ist
ja fühlen sich momentan ganz viele
hoffnungen für mich in kirchen akteuren
und das ist das ist wundervoll weil man
muss gleichzeitig sagen über über
hunderte von jahren wie wir alle wissen
hexenverfolgung inquisition
kolonisierung von anderen kulturen hat
die kirche eine sehr negative rolle
gespielt das ändert sich und wenn ich
das mit dem film unterstützen kann bin
ich bin ich echt dankbar wenn es
betrifft ja noch milliarden von menschen
die sich ausrichten tatsächlich nach der
meinung der kirche insofern ist sie ist
sie wirklich von belang
und trotzdem ist ihr jesus ja weitgehend
nicht religiöser so zentrale punkte in
der bibel wie etwa das reich gottes wie
heilungen und wunder außer auf dem aus
auf dem wasser gehen bei in dem film
werden sehr stark ausgeklammert ich habe
mich dann gefragt weshalb muss man da
auf die bibel zurück greifen wenn sie
eben nicht stark diesen religiösen zu
haben und stattdessen quasi wie einen
anderen spartacus zeigen ja also ich
glaube ich gesagt dass dieser etwas was
schon heidnische wunder glaube da in der
kirche und in der schule religion und
auch in der biber noch seine rolle
spielt nicht mehr wirklich wirklich von
belang ist dass ich glaube schon dass
das jesus historisch denkt ist das
nachgewiesen und patricks angewendet
hatten die leute mit special effects
hinter sich zu scharen
ich habe das auch im film beispielsweise
ligny wird ein lepra kranke geheilt er
trägt da auf und kann gehen sind extrem
schwache szenen und ich hatte das gefühl
pasolini glaubt nicht mal dran
bei mir geht das so weit dass als ich
die auferstehung gedreht hatte gemerkt
habe ich glaube nicht daran dass das das
verhältnis auf schweizerdeutsch zu sagen
ich brauche etwas woran ich heute
glauben kann und ich glaube nicht dass
man glaube und wunder glaube das ist
vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt das
gleiche einverstanden aber da klammern
sie trotzdem das reich gottes außen wenn
man die seligpreisungen nimmt und da ist
es ganz zentral das was quasi all diesen
leuten die hoffnung gibt ist die
verheißung auf dieses reich gottes und
auch das eingehen darin das aufgehen in
gott das klammern sie aus das kommt bei
mich vor
ja das ist für mich immer nennt also ich
glaube wirklich dass reich gottes also
nennen sie mich ein romantiker und
sentimental ist
auf der erde sich sicher fühlen ich
glaube wirklich wir haben nur dieses
leben ich glaube das einzige was uns
reden treten kann ist unser gemeinsames
dasein ist unsere solidarität
das interessante ist ja das letzte wort
was jesus sohn gottes spricht mein gott
warum hast du mich verlassen auch direkt
von gott verlassen
auch er braucht
seine mutter seine mitstreiter und die
anderen menschen
also wir sind allein wenn wir nicht
gemeinsam dass gott da mitspielt also
nicht dass das wirklich mir das zu
beurteilen ich habe darüber keine
meinung aber die bibel sagt relativ klar
wir müssen das hier im jetzt machen
jesus sagt dass zu dem tempel herren das
ist glaube ich eine ganz zentrale
botschaft können sie aber dass noch
etwas näher nach zeichen genau da
angeschlossen was hat denn dieser
gekreuzigte jüdische wanderprediger
jesus mit dem anführer dieser kampagne
die gegen die sklavenarbeit dagegen die
sklavenarbeit arbeitet wo sich einsetzt
was haben die genau was hinter die
verbindungslinien die ganz konkreten
also was jesus ja in der bibel macht
dieser wandel bringt geben da macht
diese tricks die sie so toll finden aber
er macht ja ich habe gesagt ich finde
sie toll ich sage sie kommen bei ihnen
nicht so anhört dass ein hund und was er
aber eigentlich macht ist ein ganz
großes casting und das war für mich
immer das berühren das ist auch im film
von personen ist sehr schön er geht an
die ränder der gesellschaft und er sucht
sich im grund die letzten in vielerlei
hinsicht da ist ja auch in zellen oder
bari
da ist eine prostituierte dabei wie man
weiß dass sie irgendwelche sub
proletarier dabei die alle verbindet
dass sie innerhalb der gesellschaft und
in bezug auf ein heilsversprechen nicht
die besten kandidatinnen sind und dass
die letzten die ersten sind das ist für
mich eine eine ein schlüssels im grunde
zu diesem buch das casting ist für mich
der schlüssel nachher gibt es noch einen
anderen schlüssel der mich interessiert
das haben wir auch wir sind auch auf die
suche gegangen könnte man sagen um die
europäische kulturhauptstadt herum und
zeigen was wir gefunden haben
das andere was er uns erzählt diese
menschen sind die revolutionäre diese
menschen sind die subjekte der
revolution dass sie nicht irgendwelche
tollen anführer mit irgendwelchen vier
master abschlüssen sondern sind diese
menschen das ist ein jeder und das
letzte und das ist natürlich in meinem
film ich habe also eine art der ästhetik
des scheiterns es ist ja an nach einem
grund unserer zivilisation ist eine
figur gescheitert naja wenn manche
kräuter und genau wenn man die kreuzung
anschaut und das ist natürlich
eigentlich das schlimm
der tod den man in dieser zeit erleben
gleichzeitig genau wenn man den glauben
wieder rein nimmt ist das scheitern wird
er natürlich überwunden durch die
auferstehen die sie herausnehmen das ist
eine interessante debatte die hatte ich
mit den ricke erst leute gestorben also
der darsteller darsteller von von
pasolini bei mir dann bei mir dann
johannes der täufer und der hat gegen
franco gekämpft und er gesagt mir ja wir
haben den kampf verloren warum machst du
diesen film und ich habe gesagt man kann
kein kampf verlieren man kann ihn nur
nicht kämpfen
natürlich verliert man jeden kampf gegen
den kapitalismus zumindest in meiner in
meiner in meiner lebensspanne
wir werden nicht die weltrevolution
herbeiführen aber vielleicht werden wir
10.000 400.000 menschen ein würdiges
leben verschärfen durch diese vorteil
wege vielleicht vielleicht sind es aber
auch nur 1000 also ich glaube man sollte
nicht verzweifeln das nicht total
erlösung kommt das ist für mich noch mal
ein bisschen finde ich die problematik
dieser dieser dieser sage ich ein
bisschen mystischen interpretationen der
therapie weil sie sich ansprechen
man kann ja auch auf die kleinen erfolge
sich freuen
man kann ja unterliegen und trotzdem
gewinnen die es gibt ja irgendeinen
grund warum die menschen hunderte von
jahren später gesagt haben das hat für
uns noch belangen was dieser typen
palästina dieser wanderprediger jüdische
wanderpredigers der da getrieben hat das
steht für etwas viel größeres steht
vielleicht für den versuch der menschen
menschenwürdig zu leben insgesamt und
jünger gegen die gleichen probleme zu
stoßen
das klingt alles extrem gut ich war aber
so ehrlich ich den aufmerksam gewordenen
stehen und es ist schön dass ihr eigenes
produkt glauben aber im film gibt es
diese szene war ja diese revolte quasi
auch im film gebetet wird wohl jemand
gesagt moment mal das ist alles hier
ernst es ist wir machen hier keinen film
und da sieht man auch sie direkt also
jemand wird ziemlich wütend also man hat
ihr kampf den sie jetzt so beschreiben
gewerkschaft aber das hat man auch ein
bisschen anders gesehen also
problematisiert das ganze weil sie das
ebenso dokumentiert haben ja ja ist
natürlich ein handgriff mir den film der
geschichte
also ich hab das war ein genommen warum
ist die frage und ich habe nicht gedacht
dass sie nichts davon
[Gelächter]
vehlen klar warum also weil ich finde
dass diese noch einmal zwiespältigkeit
die dialektik der befreiung den wir im
film zeigen die immer eine
problematische ist zum beispiel ist
diese also schon die solidarität
überzeugen ist komplett paranoid die
frage ist immer auch wollen die menschen
überhaupt befreit werden wollen die
sklaven ich lieber herren seien als
revolutionäre ist auch ein großes
problem entweder den magistrat da kommt
leider ja dummerweise aber auch im
wissen der mehrheit der bürgerlichen
männerchor damit immer stärker
aber so ist das und natürlich hatten wir
viele konflikte zwischen beispielsweise
weißen und schwarzen land arbeiten weil
das ist im grunde sind das sind das
klassen die gegeneinander ausgespielt
werden die leute sagen wenn die
schwarzen zu viele rechte haben dann
haben wir ein problem ist also das ist
ja die logik des rassismus und wir haben
gesagt ihr müsst in der kampagne der
würde zusammenarbeiten das funktioniert
auch zu 80 prozent aber zu 20 prozent
geht es auch einfach probleme weil
solidarität ist ist schwierig man musste
oft so seine eigenen sachen
zurückstecken und das gilt natürlich
auch für kunst und und und aktivismus
das verstärkt sich ganz oft manchmal
gibt es reibungsflächen also das ist
eine schwierige partnerschaft beim
philosophen karl jaspers ist jesus als
der maßgebend einer von vier maßgebenden
figuren je eine neue philosophische
denkt bewegung in gang gesetzt haben was
wäre denn die neue denk bewegung bei
ihrer jesusfigur also bei meiner jesus
wirklich und und vielleicht bei aller
arbeit die wo das ein teil daraus ist
was damit zusammenhängt dass man
wirklich wieder lernen muss moral oder
wissen oder wie man das auch immer
nennen will also die schrift und das was
man tut die so genannte gesellschaft das
verhalten des konsumenten das politische
halten das verhalten als menschen in
unseren beziehungen das wieder versuchen
wirklich zusammenzubringen abzustimmen
ich glaube dass das gute leben besteht
nur darin und das muss nicht groß oder
klein also das kann in jedem bereich
stattfinden
das ist der punkt dass man quasi das
gesetz von dem wir wissen ja alle ich
glaube wenn man setzt darauf eingehen
würden was ein gutes leben werden
schnell an konsens glauben
dass wir versuchen dass jeder auf seine
weise anzuwenden wenn sie sich jetzt für
eine der drei tugenden die bei paulus
vorkommen glaube hoffnung liebe
entscheiden müssen welche wäre es
ich glaube ich würde es direkt umdrehen
ich würde sagen liebe hoffnung glaube
das wird glaube ich meine reihenfolge
ganz herzlichen dank für das gespräch
jetzt gleich gehts zu den
passionsspielen in oberammergau
entstanden sind sie aus einem
versprechen an gott während der großen
pest in europa ausgerechnet corona hat
das 400 jährige geliebte gestört wie man
darauf reagiert schauen sie am besten
selbst und nächste woche geht es hier um
den guten sex yves bost und ich sprechen
denn das sternstunde philosophie darüber
wie eine wie eine hinduistische
politische strömung tantra unsere
massagestudios erobern konnte bis dann
und haben sie einen guten sonntag
[Musik]